hey guys craig knuckles here with some  recent training footage from the middle  of a country trip i stopped in at 4 05  barbell to train the plane summer and  oklahoma city what you're about to see  is 750 for a double this was right after  700 for a set of four and as you'll see  on both of these reps right around  parallel maybe an inch or so i I'm not  overly concerned about it for me I just  squat down until my cup stop me and then  come up I don't intentionally cut squats  high and depth is purely a function of  how much mobility work I'm doing and it  doesn't affect my strength at all so  obviously mobility is crap when you're  driving 10 to 14 hours a day but things  seem to be coming together nicely don't  forget to Like and subscribe thanks